ontem eu vou assistir Atividade
Paranormal é um filme Paranormal eu sou
a pessoa normal Fui lá né paranormal e é
um filme de terror aí beleza começa o
filme de um cara conversando com duas
menininhas sendo minha filha o seu dom é
a força você vai ter que aprender a
lidar com isso apontou para outro seu
dom é o pensamento a sua força a sua
mentalidade falei pronto com as palavras
dessa daí vai dar uma morfador pra
menina vai virar Power Rangers ali né é
a família tá na casa nova começa a mexer
numas caixas acha uma câmera antiga o
que que tem que mexer hein Por que que
não deixa as coisas lá que achou lá na
casa dela lá macho começa a usar as
coisas que encontraram na casa velha vai
dar merda quando eu mudar de casa se eu
for para uma casa primeiro que eu vou
fazer é tocar fogo em tudo que tiver lá
ah mudei de casa vamos botar as camas
Vamos botar a cama box pro Satanás não
acabei embaixo Ah achei uma boneca nessa
casa antiga toca fogo que eu já assisti
Annabelle aí o cara pega essa câmera que
ele achou na casa e começa a filmar as
coisas ele começa a fazer tipo um deles
vlog só que quando ele filma a câmera
Pega umas coisas do além então é um dele
vlog do satanás né vai dar